[Music]
masks are effective
they limit the spread of covet 19.
that is the result of the largest study
of masks ever involving nearly 350 000
people across 600 rural villages in
bangladesh
researchers from the universities of
stanford and yale found
a 30 increase in mask wearing led to a
10 drop in infections
scientists believe we can't mask our way
out of the pandemic but it is one
important layer of protection besides
physical distancing testing and getting
vaccinated
welcome to your covert 19 special here
on dw i'm chris colbert in berlin
nowadays there's even an emoji for it a
round yellow face partially covered by a
piece of cloth face masks have become a
globally recognized symbol of the
pandemic
while they've been the subject of
political controversy
the simple act of covering your mouth
and nose has been and remains an
essential tool to limit the spread of
the coronavirus
at the beginning of the pandemic
professional masks were in short supply
so people around the world revved up
their sewing machines and used
handkerchiefs t-shirts and vacuum
cleaner bags to produce diy masks and
they're still used in many parts of the
world
scientists found that fabric masks
afford some protection for the wearer
and others but they usually have an
inadequate seal and block only a
fraction of the droplets a fabric mask
is better than none but there are better
alternatives
such as this simple protective piece for
the mouth and nose known as a surgical
mask
it consists of several layers of paper
and fabric with a thin wire to make it
fit over the nose
when the wearer coughs or sneezes the
surgical mask blocks the large droplets
but when inhaling air gets in through
the sides
that means it mainly protects others
from infection rather than the wearer
there are also so-called filtering face
pieces or ffp masks which are also worn
by medical personnel
they fit snugly around the nose mouth
and chin and filter out the tiniest
airborne particles
the most effective type lets no viruses
in or out
an exhalation valve makes breathing
easier but increases the risk of viruses
escaping
so an unvalved ffp mask protects both
best the wearer and those they encounter
no matter which mask you wear it can
only be effective if used with hygiene
measures like thorough hand washing and
keeping a safe distance from others
let's talk more about this with mushrik
mubarak professor of economics at yale
university in the us state of
connecticut welcome to dw now uku
authored a study whose messages masks
work tell us about what you did in order
for people in the villages in bangladesh
where you conducted the study to wear
these
masks so our study was done in two
stages the first stage is as you just
said how do we get people to wear masks
consistently and once you get them to
wear masks then we also looked carefully
and rigorously at whether that reduces
covet 19 transmission now as anybody
who's worked in development knows it's
not easy to get behavior change uh
persistent behavior change and so we
ended up doing trying out 20 different
strategies and randomized what we tried
out in different locations with
different people to see what was most
effective
and we came up with a precise
combination of four things that seem to
work to persistently increase mass
wearing
what exactly are these uh four things
that you put into action there
yeah so we use the term norm norm to
explain what these four things are
because we think it changes social norms
the n stands for no cost mass
distribution so we actually went to the
community and went door to door and
distributed free masks in rural
bangladeshi communities and as we were
distributing math the second o is for
offering information so we made a video
where kind that you know the prime
minister of the country the director of
the imam training academy the cricket
captain they recorded some information
on why it's important to wear math and
endorsing the concept
and then the m is for role modeling by
leaders so we had to engage community
leaders get their blessings to to do
this work so that everybody understood
that the whole community was behind it
and finally for reinforcement to r
it's that uh you cannot just distribute
mass and leave you actually have to go
back to the village periodically remind
people so it's sort of like you know you
go we have a mass promoter if somebody's
walking around in the village on the
road or in the markets right without a
mass we go and say interest at them
politely and say look we distributed
mass everywhere in this village why
aren't you putting yours on can you
please put it on if you forgot it can
you go back home and get it or if that's
inconvenient here's a replacement one
now with all the effort that you
put in and that you explained to us
that effort led to an increase of thirty
percent in mask wearing put that into
perspective for us these thirty percent
yeah so that's uh in some ways that's a
big increase and the reason is in the
control areas where we were monitoring
but not doing these uh interventions
only 13 of people were wearing their
mass properly right and then that goes
up to when it goes up to 42 45
that represents a tripling of mass usage
and we're even more excited by this
because
not only was it a novelty factor where
people put on the math the day that we
distributed them we continue tracking
for 10 weeks including a period after we
left the village completely and we see
that that mass wearing remains at that
40 plus percent point percentage
now that led to a 10
drop in infections
is that a lot
yeah so when you look at the so
basically you take that 10 drop and you
convert it to how cost effective is it
for us to save lives right it turns out
that this is a very cost effective way
it represents a really good investment
for governments around the world and
that ten percent you know another way to
put it is that you know that's the
aggregate effect of different things
such as in some places we tried surgical
mass in other places we tried fabric
mass and as you just pointed out
surgical mass are more effective which
is also what we find it's more higher
filtration efficiency it saves more
lives
and we find that the surgical maps are
particularly effective in preventing
infection among the elderly so for
people above the age of 60 it eliminated
a third of all infections and which is
very very large
now with the results of your study now
public will this sort of intervention be
conducted elsewhere as well
yeah so even before i publicized the
results with the world at large with the
international media right we as soon as
we started seeing the positive effects
immediately we went into action when the
crisis hit india in a big way you
remember a few months ago right and we
started uh sharing our protocol
to make it easy for governments to
implement and i'm happy to report that
already
even before the study was publicized
we've now been distributing mass to over
100 million people in bangladesh nepal
pakistan india and also now in latin
america and starting in africa
mushrik has you've become somewhat of an
expert in mask wearing tell us again in
which situations should they be worn and
where do they have no effect
yeah and i want to be careful that you
know in our case
uh you know the mass intervention was
done everywhere all at once so we i
cannot experimentally separate that oh
you know what is indoors that work and
outdoors that work because in our case
we distributed the mass at mosques which
is an indoor setting but also at outdoor
markets etc
so one of the one of the key lessons i
would take away from this is that even
though rural bangladesh is a quite
outdoors place life is generally lived
outdoors even in a setting like this
where maths are least likely to work we
see large effects that means in indoor
places it's probably likely to have even
larger effects
and based on the research in general not
just from our study
it suggests that indoor transmission
risk is high and that's where you should
be most careful about wearing masks
mushrik mubarak of yale university thank
you
thank you
and here's a look at some of the other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
the european union has committed 200
million additional coronavirus vaccine
doses to african nations eu commission
president ursula founder line said the
new donation would be fully delivered by
the middle of next year and comes on top
of 250 million jabs already committed
students in brussels have been
unenthusiastic about getting vaccinated
just 44 percent have gotten the job now
the regional government is preparing to
make the health pass mandatory for
entering bars and restaurants in a bid
to push its young population to get the
job
after 15 months tourists are returning
to the thailand's vacation island of
phuket it's part of the sandbox pilot
program in the popular resort travelers
don't need to quarantine but they do
need proof of vaccination and a negative
covit 19 test
and now it's time for our science
correspondent derek williams answering
your questions about the pandemic
is there a correlation between long
covet and obesity
carrying around too much weight experts
agree is not good for your long-term
health generally
and of course the more you carry the
more serious the effects it can
eventually have um a number of studies
have shown that during an active
infection with sars kobe 2
excess weight in an adult increases the
chances that that person will experience
a serious outcome
the reasons for that are complicated but
according to the cdc in the u.s
they include the fact that a higher bmi
or body mass index
is linked to negative impacts for
example on things like immune function
and and lung capacity so
with acute covet 19
excess weight can substantially increase
the risk of hospitalization or ending up
in the icu
or dying from the disease
however it's taken longer and proven
trickier to tie
a high bmi to to long covet the syndrome
where persistent symptoms continue to
pop up in people who've had covet 19 for
weeks or or even months
after an infection
a study carried out by american
researchers back in june
was one of the first to indicate that
those who are obese are indeed at
greater risk
of developing long covid than those who
aren't and and that conclusion appears
to be backed up
by data from the large-scale long-term
covid symptom study which tracks
symptoms in covid patients in britain
i'd say from what i've read that that
many experts seem to be pretty confident
that obesity
does increase the chances that a patient
will develop long covet but
the evidence is not yet overwhelming
[Music]
you